what's going on guys this is rob and as
you all know thor love and thunder has
been screened for critics and i haven't
seen it yet right i have not seen this
movie at all
and supposedly
i gotta keep saying supposedly here
supposedly
the
the first post-credits scene for that
movie has leaked out now i saw this on
dom's two cents so
i don't know you could take it for what
it's worth
but supposedly the first post-credits
scene in this movie or mid-credits or
whatever
is essentially hercules returning back
to to olympia to the to olympus and
finding out all the gods are dead and
being ordered by whoever it is that
survives to kill thor because basically
they blame thor for everything that's
going on now there's a couple things
that come out of this
one if thor is being blamed for the
destruction of olympus and presumably
gore the god butcher basically killing
all the olympian gods then it only means
a couple things it means one either thor
failed to stop gore when he was
attacking olympus and thor's being
blamed for it which would make the most
sense given like the relation of the
asgardians the high father or the sky
fathers and all that kind of stuff
or
gore the god butcher is a direct result
of thor's actions that thor did
something somewhere along the line and
that led to gore the god butcher but
bigger than that
is the idea that this supposedly sets up
the conflict for
thor versus hercules and thor 5. now
here's the thing right if this is the
case and again this is rumor don't take
this as an absolute this is rumor if
that's true
thor 5 will be insane because when it
comes to hercules man here's the thing
90 of the time hercules is kind of an
idiot in marvel comics not even gonna
lie not even i'm not even gonna i'm not
gonna lead you all down the primrose
path most of the time he's a [ __ ] but
there's been one occasion
when hercules was was just
ridiculously powerful and that was
during chaos war now technically
hercules wasn't powered it wasn't simply
just him by himself he was empowered and
had all these crazy abilities and all
that kind of stuff and was literally
like a multiversal force of energy right
it was crazy how powerful he was but on
any given day
hercules can hold his own against most
everybody like some of the heaviest
hitters the incredible hulk so on and so
forth i mean guys like zeus yes like
there's literally a comic called the
incredible hulks written by greg pack
where zeus beats the hell out of the
incredible hulk and i mean it's not even
close like it's the incredible whole
kind of puts up a fight a little bit i
guess but for the most part he just gets
wrecked it's not even it's not even
close but hercules can hold his own
against most people now what's what's
really cool about this is say for
example we get that we get four five we
have a conversation between hercules and
thor i would bet all the money in my
pockets to all the money in your pockets
that they would kill for that that's
where the road of thor ends that thor
basically dies at the hands of hercules
exactly how that would happen i'm not
entirely sure but i would bet that thor
dies right chris hemsworth is one of the
last holdouts of the original roster of
the avengers right the original avengers
team from the first movie he's one of
the last holdouts right hawkeye is like
the other one basically but everybody
else is for the most part gone black
widow's gone iron man's gone captain
america is gone i guess the incredible
hulk's still there so the incredible
hulk hawkeye and black widow they're
still around i don't think the
incredible hulk is long for this world
to be honest with you guys but i think
that's what they would end up doing is
killing off thor and if that's the case
hercules would take its place because i
imagine that if the two of them fought
and hercules killed thor that it would
likely be the result of some kind of
misunderstanding or something like that
right hercules doesn't get the full
situation or whatever the case may be
and thor basically ends up dead i could
definitely see hercules taking its place
because here's the thing to know in
marvel comics they they had a series
right so you basically have the
incredible whole comic right and the
incredible hulk comic goes on and on and
on and on and it's been on for for
decades and decades
following the events of planet hulk and
world war hulk the incredible hulk bruce
banner was basically put in a prison
three miles below
somewhere in new mexico i can't remember
which what it was called uh it's not
santa fe but it was like roswell or
something like that anyway he was
basically putting a prison underground
and he was held there because of how
everything transpired during the events
of world war hulk he was deemed too
dangerous of a threat so following that
marvel created two comics that spun out
of the incredible hulk the first one was
the story that focused on red hulk and
the second one was the incredible
hercules and it was basically hercules
kind of playing the role of the
incredible hulk without the powers and
hanging out with amadeus cho this guy's
a host right he's one of the big heavy
hitters of marvel despite the fact that
he's kind of depicted as goofy and you
don't see him all that often he's a
hardcore guy and for the most part when
it comes to marvel comics whenever the
heroes are killed off and replaced by
somebody else that person is usually
some spiritual continuation of that
character so the sister of black widow
is herself a black widow so it would
make sense that natasha romanov dies her
sister is going to end up on the
thunderbolts or something like that and
then ultimately she ended up becoming
part of one of the new avengers right
she'll realize that contessa lied to her
duped her tricked her whatever that
hawkeye didn't really like leave her
sister to die that her sister chose to
die right hawkeye told her that but like
in the moment obviously she wasn't gonna
believe it she's gonna have to discover
some kind of proof on her own and then
she'll realize that hawkeye was right
and then she'll turn code against the
thunderbolts if that's the team she ends
up on but she probably will and then
she'll join the new avengers right
that's how that transpires she-hulk the
incredible hulk like kate bishop hawkeye
it's always the same way right it's
always the same thing the characters
that get replaced are replaced with
continuations of their characters so it
makes perfect sense that hercules being
an olympian god albeit not necessarily
an asgardian god would replace thor more
so than that just on speculation here i
wouldn't be surprised if thor 4
introduces the sky fathers and i'll talk
about that in a future video because i
do want to talk about the impact that
having the sky fathers would have on the
mcu but i have it i have a hard time
believing that zeus would be around for
a lengthy period of time albeit odin is
actually older in the comics i don't
know that's the way in the mcu but i
have a hard time believing they would
have been around for that long and that
you never would have they never would
have talked to each other or met each
other or encountered each other or
anything like that i think the sky
fathers are there i think they exist i
think zeus is well aware of the fact
that odin died i think that in that
movie there might be some general
conversation where they talk about that
kind of stuff and it's like you know i'm
sorry to hear about your father he was a
great man that kind of a thing and zeus
actually tells thor like we're the sky
fathers your father my father these
other gods that exist out there are all
part of the sky fathers and that these
different gods are being killed off by
gore hence why we're seeing zeus
involves in the first place so i think
that's one of the things that's going to
transpire but i think it's part of the
greater picture here part of the bigger
pantheon if thor does face off against
hulk if this leak is supposedly true
right if that's actually the case and
you do end up seeing hercules introduced
to the mcu hercules is going to replace
thor it just it seems to be the the most
logical situation because as of yet in
the mcu you don't have two variations of
the same character running around who
are that closely linked to one another
all right it's not like andrew garfield
or toby maguire just stayed in the mcu
while tom hall and spider-man went
forward and did his thing and the world
basically forgot who peter parker is and
all that stuff we didn't get that right
like we don't have two spider-men
running around we still only have one
spider-man at any given time they keep
their roster relatively small i don't
think that'll last and if ever there
were a time to give us like two heavy
hitters like that where you have like
two members of a godly pantheon who are
very close in in
you know structure and form and function
to one another like thor and hercules if
ever we were gonna have a continuation
that's it because chris hemsworth has
been very very like cloaking dagger
right smoking mirrors about his future
in the mcu he's like man i really can't
wait to see what thor does next in the
mcu and it's like well is that jane
foster or is that chris hemsworth and
he's like well i mean you know it could
be either one you know and there's times
where he's like you know this is this is
my final act right this is my swan song
i'm done after this so he's gone back
and forth we don't really have a
definitive answer and nobody's really
seemed to have come clean on which one
is which but i would bet good money that
they would introduce hercules in thor
five or at least in the post-credits
scene here him and thor will fight in
thor five and that'll be the end of thor
and you'll basically end up getting
hercules that takes over right that just
becomes the new the new guy right the
new replacement thor and you just go
forward from there now rumors abound as
to who it is that would play the
character of hercules i don't really
know who that person would be and i'm
curious who your pick is i haven't
really seen anybody or really even
looked up anybody that would stand out
to me as a replacement hercules or
hercules in the mcu but i guess that's
possible right whoever that person
happens to be i mean obviously they'd
have to fit the part they'd have to be
muscular that kind of a thing but i
don't know exactly how this would
transpire right so i don't know let me
know what you guys think right do you
think this this this post-credit scene
leak this rumor is true why do you think
we will actually end up seeing hercules
introduced in four five because we
haven't seen him in the movie or at
least in the trailers anyway and i would
have to believe because they showed us
zeus surely they would show us hercules
even if it's only a glimpse right a
single frame because what they gave us a
zeus is not enough to know what role his
character is going to play the trailer
is literally just like zeus is here
we'll see in theaters like that's
basically it
that's all the trailer gives us so i
wouldn't think it would be that much of
a stretch to show us hercules so that's
the cool thing because i feel like
there's going to be a lot of discussion
and a lot of conversation in this movie
or a lot of revelation about the earthly
pantheon of gods so let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
right let me know how you guys feel
about this and if you do think it's true
let me know who you think should play
hercules in thor 5. but with that being
said we're going to bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace